this morning in our series issues that
matter we are focusing on the opioid
crisis its impact on Americans across
the country and how to deal with this
epidemic according to the CDC almost
400,000 Americans died from prescription
and illicit opioid overdoses between
1999 and 2017 in 2017 more than 2.1
million Americans were addicted to
opioids
yesterday a 260 million dollar
settlement was reached between two
counties in Ohio and for drug companies
lawsuits brought by more than 2,600
cities counties and Native American
tribes nationwide are still being
resolved a recent report shows the
largest drug companies distributed
seventy six billion with a B pain pills
at the height of the nationwide epidemic
well this Saturday the Drug Enforcement
Administration is hosting a national
prescription drug take-back day that's
where you can turn in your unused and
unwanted medications
no questions asked acting DEA
administrator autumn Dillon is here to
discuss the initiative good morning and
also before we get to that I do want to
get you on the record regarding this
inspector general report that came out
last month now I know you're new to the
DTA new to the DEA not responsible to
the for what is being criticized in this
report but it does say that regarding
the opioid epidemic the DEA was quote
slow to respond and how slow well as
overdoses were increasing the quota that
the DEA allowed to be prescribed and
distributed went up 400% so given those
numbers does the DEA share some blame
for this epidemic
well the DEA welcomes the findings of
the Inspector General and it's important
to realize that that report covers a
period of time for fiscal year 2010 to
fiscal year 2017 over the last few years
DEA has made many improvements let me
just give you a couple of examples
DEA sets the quotas for manufacturers of
these addictive opioids since 2016 we
have reduced the quota by 47 percent our
2020 quota will reduce it by 53 percent
so that means more than half of the
drugs will no longer be available for
four
distribution illegally would you call
that a correction well I would it would
be I think it's fair to say that is a
correction based upon our understanding
of what's needed in the medical and
research communities so DEA works very
hard to determine every year the correct
amount of these addictive opioids that
need to be manufactured for all medical
and research purposes and based upon our
research these reductions are
appropriate also remember we have to
ensure that we don't have a shortage of
these drugs so it's important to find
that correct balance and we believe with
our 2020 quotas we found that balance
what are you hoping to accomplish with
national prescription drug buyback Day
well a national prescription drug
take-back day is an opportunity for
Americans to clean out their medicine
cabinets of unwanted unused and expired
prescription medications and bring them
to a collection location near them our
goal is always the same every year
we discovered that people become
addicted to the medications in their
homes in their medicine cabinets friends
and families friends and family members
will take these and that will begin the
cycle of drug addiction and abuse we
find that people bring those in those
drugs aren't available for people to
become addicted to so you do not flush
them down the toilet because do not
flush it down the toilet I don't need to
go and and turn these in that's bad for
the environment yeah remember everything
we collect we destroy an EPA approved
incinerators so it's environmentally
they're destroyed in an environmentally
friendly way I was interested to read
that vape pens are part of what you're
accepting is this give back no questions
asked absolutely for the first time ever
we're going to be accepting vaping
products and vaping devices so people
who are uncertain about a product they
may have feel free to bring it to a
take-back location there them.this why
don't you add them to the list mister
well because things have it's it's clear
that people have concerns about these
there's been obviously reports of people
actually dying from using certain vaping
products so if you have a vaping product
you have one or a family member has one
and you're uncertain about its safety at
its quality feel free to bring it into a
collection location this Saturday how
else is a DEA responding to the the
vaping epidemic the epidemic illnesses
well the DEA is working with the FDA
criminal investigators to find
individuals and companies who are
manufacturing
vaping products that are dangerous one
of the things that we've noticed that
the Drug Enforcement Administration is
that drug trafficking organizations the
kind of organizations that that
distribute marijuana cocaine heroin
fentanyl and alike are also getting
involved in vaping products and so we're
attacking the problem that way also and
so many people get hooked on opioids
from their doctors what's being done to
make sure that doctors are doing the
right thing well over the last year or
so DEA has been working with medical
practitioners doctors and pharmacists
that alike to educate them about over
prescribing and we've had great progress
we've actually seen prescription rates
for these addictive opioids go down by
almost 30% in the last year's how do you
educate them how do you wonders well
actually it's interesting doctors are
always through medical school they don't
learn about the issues of over
prescribing and that sort of thing and
so one of the things we teach them is
that oftentimes the medications and we
work with Health and Human Services also
on this oftentimes the amount of
medications that they're prescribing are
unnecessary people don't need 30 days
worth of opioids often times three four
five six seven days will be sufficient
that alone has caused a 30 percent
increase and how much of you drugs have
you collected on national take-back day
since since 2010 since the first began
and we do it twice a year at April and
October we've collected almost 6,000
times of us Wow it is working thank you
very much you Jim Dylan for your time
today
national prescription drug take-back day
is this Saturday October 26 you can go
to our website CBS this morning dot-com
to find out where you can drop off your
unused or expired prescriptions and
again no questions asked